this has been a long kept secret a long
kept secret why did you keep the
relationship under wrapped so the real
reason was we just want a privacy all
our friends and family knew we were
together our kids all that stuff but we
were never private no we go out all the
time but it never
dawned on me like we didn't want to make
it public public gotcha so but what
happened is I started traveling more and
DJing La Miami New York you know like
all over the place and we would go
together so instead of jumping the chart
we pretty much you know let's just
organize something and then we'll come
out publicly because it's going to keep
on happening we're going to travel more
together and it'll be more notoriety
right and I'm hearing that while you all
were traveling and the relationship is
under wraps that Stephanie you were
pretending to be Hannah's friend oh yes
in one occasion I was because you're
there for her mostly but she wanted my
support so it was easy enough to just
say I was an older college student he
also respected my wishes because it's a
lot obviously like since we've been out
it is a lot
and I am thankful a lot of good things
have been said but you know it's good or
bad but a lot of it was like it was a
new thing I we both had a lot of not a
lot of relationships but a lot of years
invested in people and I just didn't
know where this would go and I respect
him and I know he respected me so that's
why we kind of just again we were not
private we'd kiss in public around here
anywhere we went but we were just
cautious if I saw a camera
yeah especially in major cities though
like obviously we live out here in the
country or suburbs or whatever and
people are more conservative when we go
to like Miami and New York it's more
business yeah you know Paparazzi and and
the likelihood of that is about to
happen so we flew it out of Miami for a
shoot with Hannah
so the first time I walked right into
the Mondrian Hotel in South Beach and
there is like Paparazzi and I knew like
half of those guys and they're like oh
hey John how are you I'm like uh I'm
good still in that moment Stephanie
because he did tell them like you know
no pictures and it's you know it's new
we have children involved so
and we're happy like we're we have to
behave a little bit in public we're
going home together later so it's fine
yeah you know but how has it been
getting into this whole media Madness
and did anyone in particular warn you
maybe you shouldn't get involved with
John Gosling well my mom flew out of her
recliner when I thought I was dating him
no way really flying out of the recliner
in a good way or a bad I was like okay I
finally I was like not dating anymore
and I was like I found somebody and I
told her who it was and but now the
greatest thing is that they they talk
everything she knows more about our
relationship than I do really so how did
you win her mother over John she talks
her every day I just treat her like a
normal person
what do you think she's I think we have
the same personality we're both black
and white so we just say how we feel and
what's going on so we tend to just like
get along on the same page and our
Outlook in life is pretty much the same
so what do you think it was about
Stephanie's mom that had her be a little
cautious reluctant about her daughter
dating you oh I think of people that
read tabloids and read into tabloids
obviously I'm out there a lot
um and maybe talk to other people that
may or may not know too much about me I
kind of keep to myself around here I
mean I have my close friends and we go
out and stuff like that but I don't
really have ancillary people anymore in
my life so take us back to that first
day the two of you met how did you mate
we met on a backyard barbecue from a
mutual friend so who put the move on who
first Stephanie did you approach John
John did you approach I think I did
message you first I think you did I
actually probably pull it off first
because I had a really cool candle and
because we're friends with anything like
I thought you commented on my candle for
my birthday but I don't know I think I
reached out first and then we just
started just chit chatting and then I
think it was like three or four days
later he was like I'm a B2 Bistro would
you like to come over and have a drink
so I was in the gym super fit
things for all this weight and I decided
to just go over there sweaty natural
looking curly hair no makeup and he
adored me I think
oh yeah we really hit it off I mean it's
weird that you know you look at social
media and that we can have so many
mutual friends like thousands and never
run into each other there was no
interlying things or behind the scenes
things it's supposed to be an hour I was
like five hours I don't know
I don't know wow so from a backyard
barbecue to exchanges on social media to
then you asking her out you know going
out for drinks you might have been
sweaty buddy from the gym but y'all hit
it off yeah it was like great
conversation
I mean when you think about your
significant other what do you love most
about him what do you appreciate most
about him
but I actually have help for once
and I'm not saying in past life I never
had help it's just it's a lot more it's
things that I never you know as a little
girl you you know I have a great father
and he did all these things and he's
fulfilling a lot of that that I know
that I'll be okay in life like he
literally
and it feels rewarding that I can tell
them I will be okay in life he takes
very well care when he first took care
of me being sick I think that's when I
really fell in love with him
yeah yeah
but I love him because he's genuine he
doesn't even if he's as tired as I am he
he pulls that extra mile and just does
it and he doesn't make you feel bad
about it and we want I know he loves it
I don't know he don't nag we're good
yeah we don't argue that much so
what does life look like now
cohabitating together and and how are
you working things out who does what
around the house what does a typical day
look like between I take her on the
outside
but you do the inside too you just had a
feather duster out loud 20 minutes ago
before they got here and he does no he
does with a cough and you love doing the
Landscaping as well I do that's always
been my thing I'm letting him do that
because I used to do the Landscaping
myself too
your help go to 11. no I can't would you
come here because now Stephanie did you
watch John and Kate Plus Eight back in
the day what do you remember about the
show
diapers lots of diapers when you got
eight
a lot of babies running around
but I love hearing that you feel like
you had help you have help Stephanie
because some would say I mean maybe back
in the day some of the episodes of John
and Cape would say you weren't
necessarily the most helpful sometimes
John yeah I became disgruntled because
it was just like instead of asking it
was ordering being married and just
constant constant ordering I was just
like shut you shut down yeah and help I
ain't helping you I mean I don't need to
prove my point you can just go watch
season after season of That So now the
two of you you've been in a relationship
for two years now almost almost really
close to two years oh my gosh like
really close the first three close
together John a couple days it was
September like I don't know it was not
we met at that barbecue at the end of
August okay yeah yeah and then y'all
made it official not too long after
yeah a couple weeks yeah yeah you move
fast John Gosling I think I did too yeah
I think so I think everything just
clicked playing that one on him are you
all interested in expanding your
families and having more children you
cannot expand the family no well
physically not going down no no no when
are we walking down the aisle when are
you inviting ET to the wedding next
question no but I saw on Instagram
you're not engaged that wasn't an
engagement is this forever
well I hope so better be I'm not moving
I don't want to move I'm not moving it's
already told the house is so large we
have a fully finished basement
just live downstairs I'm staying
upstairs I'm not lifting a box I'm too
old
not one box I don't want to see packing
tape or bubble paper ever ever again
once we buy another house for just a
second house that's fine we'll just put
new stuff in that we're not moving yeah
for a while
why is it on me
[Music]